hi I'm Nia vardales the port of Collins
family is back in theaters on September
8th
so since the first film came out 21
years ago here's a quick refresher on
what has happened so far so you can get
ready to see my big factor recording 3.
my character Tula is a real cause of
concern for the rest of the family why
because in the first movie my character
is unmarried at 30 years old which is a
pain point because even Windex can't fix
this for her traditional parents Gus and
Maria Tula works at dancing zorbas
they're a Greek restaurant but decides
to take a job at her ant bullish travel
agency where she meets and falls in love
with Ian Miller a teacher who is tall
and handsome and definitely and not
Greek
gordocaulus
okay Tula ultimately Tula finds the
inner strength to not only stand up for
what she wants but also come out of her
shell and show her family who she truly
is there are some bumps along the way
but in the end there's of course a
wedding and Ian and Tula get there
happily ever after
in my big Factory waiting too I wrote
about parenting and marriage because you
know what it's getting tougher for
everybody Tula feels the pressure to be
the fixer their businesses have fallen
on hard times and their teenage daughter
feels like Tula is smothering her Paris
is also rebelling against traditional
Greek values of the family mom's needy
Papu wants to marry me off Yaya
constantly tells me to never ever let a
boy touch my pulaki this family when the
father Gus's attempt to convince the
family he really is descended from
Alexander the Great unearths a shocking
truth he and Maria were never legally
married the entire portocolist Clan is
sent into chaos but then a health scare
puts things back in perspective and
Maria and Gus and Tula and Ian renew
their vows before sending Paris off to
college out of state what's to come in
My Big Fat Greek Wedding 3 this time
we're headed to the Homeland recorded
Greece oh yeah
afternoon
the family is invited to a porticollis
family reunion and have a one-of-a-kind
Adventure in Greece this film is filled
with lots of fun and lots of heart and I
can't wait for you to see it this
September only in theaters please grab
your tickets now
that's fine